[موسيقى]
فانتقل بالتالي جد الاسره المالكه مانع
المريدي الى بعد ما طلبه ابن عمه ان يقضعه
ارضا فاقطعه ارض شمال حجر اليمامه وشمال
الرياض التي هي تقريبا الان الدرعيه التي
قامت على موضعا قديم يسمى موضع الضيق
وغبيره كان هذا في الجاهليه وايضا واول
الاسلام ثم تحول الى المليبيد وغصيبه
الان في الدرعيه تقع في الجهه الجنوبيه
منها في موضع يقال له العلاقيه واما غصيبه
فايضا في موقع الطريف من ناحيه الشماليه
[موسيقى]
مانع المريدي عندما بدا الحكم ايضا
والانتقال لهذه الجهه هناك انجب ابنه
ربيعه ولهذا يخلط بعض المؤرخين انهم
يذكرون مانع بالربيع المريضي وهذا ليس
صحيحا بل المانع هو الجد الاعلى وله ابن
ربيع وربيع ايضا تسلسل منه عدد من الابناء
الحقيقه بينهم تقريبا الفتره الحكم يعني
من سنه 850 الى في عام 1139 الى فتره
الامام محمد بن سعود استمر على اماره
الدرعيه من هذين الفرعين المقرن والوطبان
ايضا نتفرع منهم نعم وايضا الجد الاعلى
ابراهيم بن موسى بن ربيعه بن مانع المريدي
الذي كان ايضا هذه المنطقه وجدت له
الوثائق ايضا في الدول الخارجيه سنه 981
عندما كان ايضا يحمي هذه المنطقه